mes amis ma famille mes amis mes amis
mes amis à petit lens vous plaît merci
merci si nous sommes réunis tous
ensemble pornichet là dans la chanson
dans ce bistrot dans ce bistrot
sympathique oui c'est ce pas alors c'est
pourquoi c'est pour rendre hommage à
notre ami gaston du glandier secteur
merci beaucoup vous êtes très gentil
l'heure c'est vraiment bon mais c'est
normal c'est normal à notre ami gaston
du glandier qui après de longues années
de bons et loyaux services nous quittent
pour gagner une retraite bien méritée
une retraite une petite retraite ne peut
pas fermer bien méritée comme un a bien
mérité voilà mais si la quantité que
c'est pas la qualité c'est la quantité
c'est tout le contraire
alors voilà je vous tous vous devez vous
dire si je n'ai pas peur j'ai pas faire
un long discours je voudrais simplement
être l'avocat de tout le personnel et
toute la direction pour dire combien
nous avons apprécié votre collaboration
fidèle toujours présent l ouvrage
toujours sur le rabot toujours sur la
lime toujours sur le fer à souder
toujours partout vous étiez pas été
omniprésent 1 vous faisait vraiment
toute l'équipe entière et on voudrais
saluer votre conscience professionnelle
et ne croyez pas qu'on va se quitter
comme ça ça ne croyait pas puisque vous
avez eu la gentillesse de nous offrir
cet apéritif si généreux laissez-moi
vous offrir
laissez-moi vous offrir le verre de
l'amitié avec une paille avec une paille
aussi de rappeler les projets vous et
voilà et je lève mon verre également en
formant des souhaits les plus sincères
pour votre retraite pour vous tous ceux
qui vous sont chers votre famille et vos
amis et tous ceux qui sont à côté et
autour bon je n'ai pas l'habitude de
faire des discours oui mais tout ce que
j'ai à vous dire c'est que je vous adore
à toutes et à tous cite une phrase qui
me rappelle quelque chose c'est qu'ils
attendent et dites moi monsieur du
glandier je voudrais vous poser une
question en particulier
je voudrais vous demander quelque chose
mais j'ose pas gérer osez osez voilà
c'est une question qui m'intrigue depuis
longtemps il me dit
je la pose ne pense pas et j'ose pas la
formule est formulée formule aime se
dire ah tu vas voir je voudrais vous
demander et ça m'intrigue
pourquoi vous avez toujours mis au
travail ici tout le temps votre
casquette de côté pourquoi c'est très
simple monsieur directeur oui parce que
depuis trente ans que je travaille dans
votre boîte c'est la seule chose que
j'ai pu mettre de côté